>> So, let's recap lesson one. Our task, was to learn what
is user experience? And the steps we followed were, we defined user
experience and we gave you a super-awesome example and demonstrated how a
need for speed and portions is a really great example of user-experience.
>> That was my favorite step. Yes. And the second step was we disambiguated
UI from UX. We talked a little bit about the difference between visual and
non-visual code. We also gave you two really great
examples of how to improve your apps user experience today,
with the sign in and check out flow. And we
also touched on Lowe's wire framing, which is a really
great technique for starting at the high level and not
focusing on the details to start with. So in Lesson
two, you're going to learn how to make applications that people
love to use, by focusing in on your end user.
But before we get into lesson two, you're
going to watch some interviews from some real users.
>> Yeah, and as you're watching these videos
of real users actually interact with applications, make
a note of what makes them unhappy, and
what makes them happy, in, in these applications.
>> And also make a mental note of whether the
things they mention are related to visual or non-visual code.